pi is next
for perimeter that's the phonetics and
the perimeter of a circle you can get
that invoking the constant pi right and
march 14th is pi day uh all over
the world if you keep your calendar as
the month preceding the day 3.14 is the
first three digits of pi and that gets
you pretty far even though they're many
many more digits so uh pi is the
if you take this circumference the
perimeter of a perimeter of a circle
divide by its diameter right
then
you've got the number pi and that's no
matter the size of the structure the
size of the circle yeah because the once
one gets bigger the other gets bigger
you divide out pi shows up very
important a constant not only in math
but in the entire universe